what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we run over all the
news and rumors and tidbits and all the
stuff you may have missed
over the course of the week and we have
a big
episode today hugh jackman wolverine the
marvel cinematic universe but before we
get
into that kind of a crazy thing and i
feel like everybody saw this coming
marvel and dc are supposedly gonna have
no role in san diego comic-con in 2021
instead
opting to host their own events and this
makes sense right san diego
is going to be an all virtual event this
year kind of the tail end of what's
going on with cons
going into the post covid landscape i
imagine by next year everything will
basically be back to normal and i think
maybe there's a handful of cons here and
they're going to be doing in-person
events but with san diego it makes a lot
of sense it's the biggest comic book
convention in the world that's not
associated with anime the anime cons are
the biggest ones but
the comic-con scene san diego's where
it's at although arguably i think new
york is as big
if not bigger the important thing is
they're going to be hosting their own
events here and i feel like a lot of
companies are going in that direction we
talked last week or maybe the week
before how a lot of the video game
companies that are out there
are not really taking part in events
like e3 instead they're launching their
own events maybe it's cheaper i'm not
entirely sure
but it kind of sucks i feel like you
know the whole hall h event and the idea
of san diego and marvel goes on there
and makes their announcements and dc
goes in there and makes their
announcements all that kind of stuff
it's just kind of a
past time right it's one of the things
that you look forward to when it go when
it comes
to the comic book convention so it's
gonna be disappointing but at the end of
the day
i guess it's just par for the course but
the next bit of news here this is kind
of a crazy thing the marvel cinematic
universe is no longer inking these huge
contracts with actors and actresses
specifically they cited chris evans and
chris hemsworth but i imagine they also
included robert downey jr now i think
rdj
is a bit of a special case here because
the entirety of the marvel cinematic
universe was in large part
built on the shoulders of robert downey
jr right the success of iron man is what
led to all the other franchises that
came after
now that's not to say that chris evans
chris hemsworth all those different
actors bradley cooper as rocket raccoon
vin diesel as groot literally saying
three lines throughout the entirety of
his whole marvel cinematic universe
appearances it's not to say they didn't
contribute anything to the mcu but we
can all kind of agree
had it not been for robert downey jr
specifically his portrayal of tony stark
which i would say is the role he was
born for
we wouldn't really have the mcu as it
exists but there also are huge
limitations there money that could be
spent on hiring a particular actor is
money that could actually be spent
hiring
multiple actors now this really begs the
question are we going to see
these great big huge long appearances
are we going to see people like
chris evans and chris hemsworth in the
future of the mcu right angelina jolie
for example is going to be in eternals
are we going to see her in the mcu for
the next 10 years or
are they going to get rid of her
character in about five years and just
move on to the next one one of the
things to know when it comes to the mcu
everything you've seen over the last 10
or so years has been the very tip of the
tip of the tip of the iceberg
they haven't even gotten to the x-men
yet and there are a mountain of
characters they can use there the marvel
cinematic universe if we're being honest
with ourselves can make movies for the
next 100 years
just based on the entirety of the marvel
roster and even then they would just be
getting started right so they can make
movies forever at the end of the day
the length of the marvel cinematic
universe's success doesn't really have
so much to do with the characters so
much as the general public's interest in
their movies that will really determine
the livelihood and the length of how
long the mcu goes on for
but moving away from comic books for a
second and talking a little bit about
gaming here
some poor soul donated air raid by
accident to goodwill or at least
supposedly by accident why does this
matter
air raid was an old atari game and there
were less than 30 of them made this game
in pristine condition is worth about 10
grand and in fact it sold for about 11
grand at auction
by goodwill that person has to be
kicking themselves
not the most significant thing in the
world but i just kind of felt like that
needed to be talked about
if you guys are going to donate stuff
make sure you check the value of the
things you're donating
there's nothing wrong with donating high
value items that can be sold by charity
centers for a good chunk of change they
need it
right those people those those
organizations aside from goodwill more
the local places run on a shoestring
budget so any
kind of charitable donations they can
get that can help bolster their budgets
and increase their finances is always a
good thing
you just don't want to be the person who
does it by accident
[Laughter]
don't be the person who donates a ten
thousand dollar game and then kicks
yourself for not really looking up the
value of it now most likely it was just
some
grandma who donated all of her kids
atari stuff or whatever it is who really
knows right i feel like
old people don't really have an
understanding of the value of stuff like
atari games and what they're worth now
versus the 10 cents they paid for them
at the time that they
came out i don't really know but
regardless it's one of those weird and
wonky circumstances
but one of the other things that we
found out here is that the new
assassin's creed game is going to be a
live
service game i'm going to be honest with
you guys i missed the days when i could
just
go to the store buy a game and i got the
whole package in the game itself
i understand that game makers are
creating games for
like shareholders and the stock market
they're not really making it for the
gaming community
i guess they are insofar as like we're
buying them but their job and their goal
is to appease shareholders first and
then gamers second
and having this whole system set up
where i'm basically being nickel and
dimed after i pay
60 to 70 dollars for a game kind of
pisses me off
it's one of the reasons why i stopped
playing destiny i'm really tired of that
i don't want to turn this into a great
big huge tirade
just railing against games as a service
but i think it's high time that we just
stopped participating in that right stop
participating in this idea of games as a
service
and saying okay we're going to pay 60
for the base game and then by the time
we get all the expansions we've paid
about 200
i think it's a huge colossal waste right
the best way to combat that is to show
game developers we're not buying into
that nonsense and basically stop
partaking in it
one of the last little announcements we
have here for the gaming scene and i'm
not really sure
how to feel about this death stranding
is getting a ps5
port and much like ghost of sashima it's
getting a director's cut which basically
means additional content the game
death stranding was gorgeous but i was
bored out of my mind it was just so
slow and i understand that hideo kojima
games are designed to be like that right
they're designed to tell a story
more than focus on the gameplay the
story was great and it was fantastic
but at the end of the day it just wasn't
really able to hold my injuries i kind
of had to force myself through it but at
the end of the day
i'm just not a big fan of it right it's
just way too slow i have adhd man
i like games that are fast paced i like
it when things happen but regardless as
beautiful as it was on the ps4 i can
only
imagine how it's gonna look on the ps5
that game
i think will really highlight what the
ps5 is capable of but at the end of the
day
we'll just kind of have to wait and see
and find out but but getting into our
final bit of an announcement here of
course hugh jackman kevin feige all that
kind of stuff the black widow movie
comes out at the time of this recording
i have not seen it yet but i am excited
to see it i'm curious to see what they
do with taskmaster those of you guys who
don't know
tony masters is the premier fighter in
marvel comics right
this guy was technically born with
muscle memory so he can see people do a
thing and then he just
remembers it and so he was able to watch
captain america fight or watch somebody
like shang chi fight
and the longer he fights someone the
more he begins to mimic their style
this was expanded upon with a serum that
he took which actually enhanced his
ability to do this
we could do it much much faster but the
cool thing about taskmaster is if he
gets into a fight with captain america
the longer they fight the more he'll be
able to copy his fighting style all the
way to the point that he'll actually
know what captain america is going to do
before he does it kind of a precognition
of sorts i'm curious to see how they
roll the character over
into the black widow film if i'm a
betting man it's probably not going to
be tony masters the black widow film
has largely come across as something
akin to wonder woman where it's largely
a woman-centric film which i think is
awesome
and so they'll probably end up turning
tony masters into a woman as opposed to
a guy
now whether or not it's still the whole
idea of like a muscle memory type thing
i don't really know i think it's gonna
be cool to see a person fighting black
widow
red guardian and so on who basically
switches between the fighting styles of
different people iron man maybe i don't
think iron man really has a fighting
style
assuming the taskmaster has seen uh seen
black panther fight he could switch into
that fighting style
so go from like captain america to black
panther to spider-man and just kind of
switch around all over the place to the
point
that the fighting style is incredibly
confusing for anybody who's facing off
against it and that's what gives them
the upper hand
but for our big discussion here right
our biggest rumor of the day right hugh
jackman kevin feige
wolverine in the mcu we know it's only a
matter of time before wolverine shows up
in the marvel cinematic universe but
what's been happening here
is that hugh jackman has been basically
adding a whole bunch of images to his
instagram account
that show like wolverine right they
basically say like this is wolverine his
claws
different things like that and then
having a whole bunch of pictures with
kevin feige it's one of these things
that we've seen happen before
we saw this when chris evans was going
to play captain america but he wasn't
officially cast we saw it when prince
hemsworth was going to play thor he was
not officially cast
we saw that with different scenarios
dave bautista and drax the destroyer
that these actors and actresses would
come out
and they would show these images on
social media twitter instagram facebook
even if they used that i don't really
know but they would show these images on
their social media platforms
that basically hinted at the idea that
like a thing is coming
and it's only in rational hindsight it
was like yeah they were telling us they
were going to play that character
awesome and so using that hindsight and
applying it to this
all arrows point to the fact that
somehow or another
disney managed to get hugh jackman to
come back as wolverine
in the marvel cinematic universe and i
gotta tell you if we get hugh jackman
in the mcu as wolverine
all will be right with the world because
i gotta be honest right
i understand he played the character for
17 years i understand he's old he can't
play the character forever they'll most
likely go with somebody who's young if
they don't bring in hugh jackman
that can play the role of wolverine for
quite some time because let's be honest
with ourselves wolverine movies in the
mcu
that's the license to print money and so
at that point they would need somebody
to play the role for a long long time
but hugh jackman is wolverine man like i
can't see him as anybody else
and i can't see anybody else playing
wolverine besides hugh jackman he just
he was so good at it especially coming
out of logan logan was the best of the
wolverine films right probably the best
depiction of wolverine
in any of the fox x-men films right it
was just an incredible movie you know it
was drama
and it was action and it was just great
storytelling it was beautifully shot
of course we also know that ryan
reynolds deadpool is going to appear in
the mcu we know the deadpool 3 is going
to be rated r
and as far as we know from what kevin
feige told us it's the only movie that's
coming into the mcu that's going to be
rated r largely just because of the fact
that you know deadpool's successful
nobody wants to see a pg-13 movie
everybody wants to see an r-rated
deadpool so at that point the general
public forced the hand of
of marvel studios in disney but seeing
hugh jackman cross over with ryan
reynolds
it just screams perfection
just and i i really feel like this is
something that we just need to see right
it just needs to happen but
with that being said guys that's our
episode for this week let us know down
in the comments if there's any news that
you think we missed that we should talk
about
and we will catch you all later peace